[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and the
leaks are finally over the hype is done
the speculation is complete welcome to
your first look at the samsung galaxy s9
and the galaxy s9 plus so in general as
soon as you look at it it's pretty clear
it's a refinement of what we've already
seen with the galaxy s8 but there are a
couple couple new interesting things
worth noting so
what's new with these new phones first
of all the all new colors there's the
black like usual which is stealthy then
there's also this coral blue
and this lilac purple and then
internationally there's gonna be a
silver titanium one again i mean yeah
samsung tends to be using the super cool
color scheme for these phones i'm not
the biggest fan i'll probably still end
up using the black one but the mirror
finish stays it's still super shiny and
reflective like the past couple years
this is probably a phone you'll end up
putting a dbrand skin on to keep it from
looking like a mess six seconds after
you take it out the box but uh yeah
they're keeping this look for now
aesthetically though the shape and the
bezels and the placement of everything
the power button the volume rocker the
bixby button everything is the same the
one thing they've moved is the
fingerprint reader now to underneath the
camera instead of next to it which i of
course actually like a lot there's no
in-glass fingerprint reader nothing
crazy like that but this is definitely
more reachable and in a better place
than it was before especially on the
smaller phone like i said though most of
this phone is going to be pretty
familiar still the 5.8 inch and 6.2 inch
infinity displays respectively still
ip68 certified still has wireless
charging still has usb type-c still has
a headphone jack the speaker got a
slight improvement uh but it's still in
the same place right at the bottom of
the phone but they added stereo
listening with this earpiece about the
top of the phone and from listening to
it it's a bit louder but not
significantly better in quality or
anything um the coolest new feature
though is it got dolby atmos surround
sound something of course that is new
though is the specs you gotta bump the
specs up to be a top-tier 2018 flagship
so they bumped it up to get snapdragon
845 and four or six gigs of ram so
galaxy s9 has four gigs of ram and
galaxy s9 plus has six gigs of ram it
also has 64 gigs of storage plus micro
sd card expansion and i've also added a
couple small things now like iris
scanning from the galaxy note and facial
recognition so there's more ways to
biometrically authenticate if it's not
just a fingerprint reader but obviously
by far the biggest change and the
biggest new feature that people are
looking forward to for galaxy s9 is the
camera all the teasers and all the leaks
and all the hype for this phone we're
all focused no pun intended on that
camera so galaxy s9 has an all new
camera system and when i say camera
system really i mean the newest most
interesting part isn't the sensor it's
the glass it's the lens so okay up until
now pretty much every smartphone camera
is so small it's so miniaturized that
they all have a fixed aperture lens you
don't change the aperture they fought
from an f 2.0 aperture down to f 1.9
down to f 1.8 f 1.7 they're all in this
battle to get as much light into the
camera as possible because that's a good
thing but something to know about
wide-angle wide aperture lenses and you
know this already if you know anything
about photography or video is the wider
you go
the softer it generally is so a lot of
photographers shooting with their lenses
will opt to stop down to f 2.4 or f 2.8
because it's sharper there it's way
sharper there than it is at f 1.8 wide
open so galaxy s 9's new camera is the
first i've ever seen in any smartphone
that can change apertures it's a
variable aperture lens so you can shoot
at f 1.5 wide open super huge amount of
light or you can stop down for more
detail to f 2.4 and you can actually see
it physically doing this and switching
when you move back and forth between f
1.5 and f 2.4 it's a pretty obvious
difference when you get a good look at
it this is super cool to me i've never
seen such a small camera with a variable
aperture before pretty sure gopros don't
do this most tiny cameras smaller than a
point-and-shoot don't do this this is
really impressive for a smartphone so
the goal with the software is to quickly
and smartly switch between the wide open
and stopped down depending on how much
light there is in the scene i was told
it defaults to the f 2.4 and then it
opens up to the wide under about 100 lux
which is actually a really low light
which means it's doing it as more of a
low light mode but i'm doing the
switching you see here in pro mode which
has a button for it so you'll be able to
switch to f 1.5 whenever you want so i'm
definitely going to keep my eye on this
for the full review going to be testing
it pretty hard to see if it really makes
a difference and i have a feeling it's
going to be a pretty big deal if you can
see the difference between f 1.5 and f
2.4 photos on this phone but until then
fingers crossed and then there's a bunch
of other new camera features tossed in
there as well like it will do slow
motion video it'll do 240 frames per
second at 1080p which is pretty awesome
and it will do
960 frames per second
at
720p so i did get to test this on the
pre-production units it's super slow
motion obviously but i'm not sure i can
vouch for the quality that's why i throw
the air quotes in there but even in this
well-lit room you can see a lot of grain
i'd like to test this outdoors though
maybe with something super slow like an
explosion or something i think a lot of
people don't really realize how
impressive 960 frames per second video
is especially on a smartphone where
you're writing all that to the memory as
fast as possible but it stretches 0.2
seconds of video
to six seconds of footage that's like
turning this
into a movie now number one it doesn't
record audio which that's probably fine
you don't really hear anything important
with super slow motion video anyway so
it sort of overlays this music of your
choice which is neat i guess but number
two
is it only records
0.2 seconds of video and we were trying
this
you have to get really smart about what
exact fragment of time you want to
record but they have this automatic
motion detection feature where basically
you tell it to wait for fast motion
inside a certain box you hit start and
then it waits for something to happen
inside the box and records 0.2 seconds
of that so you can frame it up and move
the box anywhere on the screen it's cool
when it works i'll try it out there is
also in the camera
a better ui for swiping through the
different modes now similar to the
iphone there's better multi shot for
noise reduction and hdr capabilities
there's some bixby improvements so it'll
recognize it'll do object recognition
things like what google lens is doing
and it'll also live translate signs that
are in different languages so that's
cool and something else interesting was
it will overlay
makeup on you and then if you like it
it'll give you a link to buy that makeup
i guess that's pretty neat but there's
even something they're calling ar emoji
ar emoji
r emoji
animoji ripoff it's a feature that uses
that uses the front-facing camera to
create an animated version of your
likeness so you can use that to record
and send videos of yourself
as this animation talking to people or
you can make yourself an animal too no
big deal but bottom line all this stuff
all this new stuff in the camera is what
makes it pretty clearly the biggest new
feature of galaxy s9 so that's what i'm
looking forward to testing the most for
the full review definitely make sure to
get subscribed if you haven't already to
be among the first to see that but other
than that it is for sure the phone we
were expecting it's what we were looking
forward to and it's still premiumly
priced just barely below the galaxy note
i think the one thing that'll be more
interesting to note this year is the
bigger difference between galaxy s9 and
galaxy s9 plus they used to be pretty
close and i actually think i almost gave
an award to galaxy s8 for being so close
to its bigger brother as far as feature
set but this year the galaxy s9 plus not
only gets a bigger screen and more
battery but it also gets more ram
and more camera so there's a bigger
separation there a bigger buying
decision but either way it comes out
march 16th and uh the pre-orders start
march 2nd so just in a couple days so
let me know what you think is this
camera all this new camera stuff enough
to get you in line to get a galaxy s9 or
maybe you're gonna keep waiting on some
other flagships let me know
until the next one until the review
thank you for watching
talk to you later peace
you